it's a laundry list of things that have
happened with Antonio Brown the last
week that for some reason I don't hear a
lot of people talking about know during
the game he was seen yelling at
teammates and coaches on the sideline
after he was pulled last week a reporter
came out and was I guess writing about
the Steelers and he responded on Twitter
with to the guy wait till I see you bro
we're gonna see what your jaw is like
and didn't respond and then had to do an
apology right and then after the game on
Sunday he left the locker room
immediately
it's reminding me of something we talked
about during his Gatorade fiasco it
reminded me of when he did the Facebook
live in the the locker room he is doing
things and no one's talking about that
if Odell did these things everybody
would be talking I mean I know you and
me were on the same page with that story
right away because you know we've always
felt like Odell has been treated
unfairly and not saying he's been
perfect but I just don't understand I I
was shocked that no talk shows this
morning or talking about everyone's
fantasy star player is threatening the
media of throwing shots at his jaw like
not even a story where I just feel like
if Cam Newton said that it Ben
Roethlisberger said that if Odell
Beckham jr. said that if Tom Brady said
that everyone would go this is the
problem with this guy if Dez Bryant ever
say that he's not even on a team I know
like all of them would have been held to
a different standard
why is he Antonio I read differently I I
don't know is it because he has a
million-dollar smile is it because he's
a six round pick that's what I was
confusing so so he's the under you know
he's the every man's dream guy yeah
underdogs underdog story is that what it
is is it just hey listen I he does have
a million-dollar smile he's great on
social medias this is boom I get it he's
got charisma
is there anything to the fact that he
was the only guide us to support levy on
bail could there be an issue there and
then remember I brought this up in the
meeting earlier today we don't meetings
for the podcast this is present moment
that's for the show but I said he was
also the guy who were earlier this all
season he was berating all the local
media for never being able to just walk
around Miami everyone's writing a story
about him are taking shots at him it
looked it looks like he's getting tired
of the gold the the fishbowl yeah right
it looks like he's being he's tired of
people debating him or arguing about him
it just he seems almost fed up with it
what and it's bleeding into the field
yeah I would be tired to what why is he
reading tweets like why well what are
you what what do you care that well it's
hard for you as an on social media user
yes a lot of us it's just kind of
ingrained where we open our phone we
check Twitter we click on that little
mentions thing and we interact with
people okay like I also think it's hard
for him right because I bet if you're
the six round draft pick that goes out
there the first few years and you're not
really doing commercials yet but you're
killing it on fantasy all of your
mentions are I love you bro you're the
best bro and now he's starting to get
some of that negativity and maybe he's
just not used to seeing I'm right yeah
because I'm sure you went in there and
he's like hell yeah pop that dopamine
positive positive positive positive and
now he's just not used to it damn I mean
just can't he go on Twitter and not read
stuff about him or go back to the old
what did you do learn go back to the old
Kris sim sang I'm sick of unqualified
people making qualifying statements
about I mean who the hell cares what
that guy's saying yeah he doesn't really
know so when you're that big and that
famous letting anybody be able to
communicate to you just does not sound
like a smart idea or something I'd want
no you know a bad look yesterday you
know it's a bad look because the way he
acted he didn't stand there in front of
the reporters after he threatened to
sink the guy's jaws and answer up and
own to that and then of course juju
Smith Schuster was the star receiver on
the field who's amazing so all of that
looks just bad in Antonio that he's like
not willing to be accountable for his
actions or not willing to talk to the
media unless he's the star of the show
at wide receiver
apparently he's also like tweeting at
former Steeler employees too and all
that's why I know I think there's that's
what they think they think the person he
tweeting at as an ex steal or scout or
something like that I mean I'm just
gonna ask the question yeah
how much does Tomlin need to kind of get
these guys in line who kind of lets
those guys do the thing he does he
always has and they usually repay him by
being ballers and I know it's not always
been perfect yeah they're there it's a
soap opera they're right now I don't
think there's any denying that they're
all one in one and they got to get
things straight you know in week one it
was the office that was the problem with
turnovers and the defense look good
let's not forget Tyrod Taylor's 15 for
40 they scored 21 points and one of
those touchdown drives was a 1 yard one
play drive man their defense played
amazing that for it but this week was a
different animal coming in town and the
defense fell apart and they thought they
were gonna play an easy team this week
oh but it's the Tampa Bay Bucs and Ryan
Fitzpatrick